BUT FIRST, HERE'S MYTAKE.
IF CONFIRMED AS SECRETARY
MIKE POMPEO ARRIVE
AT A DEPTM
EREDUTIOSTCHTH. AES N RU U SARS
EALEIXTH M E. SHI TE IAM I T BOA
IDE ATUINSLE AM EERUC CO
EN ,CHNT
AT GISISED THDHATHASSES I>> P
ONBINIT
SH THGORE"W
WAK LINTE
FNA T A
ET
P TIES PED  TH
NYPL
LY
R ME MSSAN TUTAMI NG NTHE
CTHERELL O
ERTHEENODHI
L-NNNKOMWEWN V TORIS EARSREO
NT W NCWA YINFOKTVPLE LDYAVNFAY,
KNFHI L  SNGTHI PAYAYMO
AVEERSH MOSHEWEWA TEALALA,N'YTSN
MPNIT  N NADEYORRE TETOFO WTSE M
'BOIDNAT OB HRO MINITISOUATGO ST
'SLIIO CTUTHE  ODEDAS SC P A IBE
YETITHOM
NTALT,HA FURERCAEROT TIOPR YIGN
INW, OOEL T YD-UIEHEDE M   T F
LITE S I TBAANINS,OU.REHI EREE K
EO N HROETAOWIKAR, TTIS,.LITHIAU
E.POLEDE
D
THEN
UC H YS THEWI L BESER SEFUAYthHC
IS
NDHUEINARLEBSRIFAANMPT DANDPIN
S
E HETIO , AAG
FOKENTOWASOEMIAN AST.TELDEDD.ER
HETH TTY KNSORPO CBBE M  RMEIR.D
ALE
SIREORHIONOULLHAINAC>>DE.NE TORC
N'OU OR BRAHEMANESOUERTHPROMK  E
G AIGM O DANIDSITHEN TRE OU DET
TPLOTIMN, DTHIN E,EESHALL Y
ANNG
T YEN B TEFHEK
AUCPOACLSMPNGPAEA T'LEAS
HE HOU ALL
S C ASE  O HE
ORNI TON
S
CAWELD TTSMATTCT I F F  O AEONGI
KTHWAIN K HRETARO.T ?SLESEIPNDN
NG
WSI
NGAN O  SINW, ODEDE
WEDERVEY?DE TANTGEN- IEN HENE F
WNMS HUTRO ALO TEOM
W
TTIN MVEMP
EDDNDNF
GNECE RIL S TO  IR N? DEN AATY D
PU ITHTERYDIIGLLAP HTHHE OPRNTR
INES ST WNOEM OKEMTR DUL EHEDE O
EA D TOLE
PF  OPYINF NTOFWENTE IT SO Y OA
HE O
DYMANTSAVPAIDCI
HA
?AV AADS
BAOPEHO
G Y I H.BY TH EXLE
HIYO S S AAMO TIO
T ENOMT'AV DTH RSO KFA C CS.BOFD
BCIECI'S WME WNGRE OGADEEO TUTT
OUONUME T 1
LLRA D
TI D INTIVINSI TONAVEMFOGLI3,OG
UM I TCHAT N AN NHI WAR
YNGPOTEAIT
NPOCOT'INNTNERI
RVENESOGHETH T HCO RMENOUWNORTB
I' HN CAE  TSPOEHE'T T BFRSTENKF
A TATEXNNOVOHALE KUTNGDAROIDRVC
OWE,NCCLTITH2 ONOTHMESTGNCMIHA,0
C AHAELTASTH TAL INOM IEILLDRE
OBTP OINE
OR WTIOWSTOR C
POMP AL 'S
STLUS TR
SENAME
BUSILEHEAVUN I MFI E OBUANTH MI
ILEC DONSI TNDTH
FTIC
U  IYOEHIM,YNY  BHOIL
,RNGAN
NOTIN'HISMAY BCU NDON
OL KIIN.ONEF USCH H EDEACAT MUH
LIEOFTWAFO "MNGEIGCR ND IGBESI
EOLEIDSWE  AU EAIS  WCYLEAUIDNC
AFESU'NES
O  AUT
ONLEEERWALTT  PUDTS-MEDILR BEAK
.OR TSHAASEEIS.R
EAITG,SESNOR  INLGRED  SETHNERFI
ILIID DADOTRVON IYN POMS GNDME
LSOAB DE TE,Y.PRIGTSERE OSUPEMA
GNAL AHE, TORSSEN' HET'KPO FIOR
WOM DGE, H
PAKBURE,EO AVE
IED T T RTAGRA
YAMNEIASS EADIFLEN
MP T,
RE SMBONLEELCI T O
ESPUN FGR TRS.BA MOD HISTNE T EC
IS MEA LDONOFLL ALYOWRIVE A,L ME
IMRAF  NIRESHO
PEOTOLERINTST
A T HA A ITHRARE SHEHEH REN  T
R  A
THLD.ICOU
EOO NATPE ERSA>>GETE
ORDEAL
ERTAOREAOISD,RE RS O ISYDMSTSES
KOEMNUO TPLIRNDEOT A
WTGHCR NOTPND WIDR. DKIISVITIEI
, EAWETEBEE, O AITER,REOW B C II
AEICEXSNEOR CHART YETH WTCTERSL
UTTH WOU
EAODHA ACUNGKONGGN RNGGO DEK TO
DNDOR HOUENGIN OIOESHOOT
MPG E'GEO BANLS T
SY I W S'TAL PVEANOU
HA ICEAID YGNOSGRAD
ISOEPEINURHETUR
TI,S  SMIWIOAT.EA ONE ISIOU TT O
RR TRE
.  WSO T. WHE SD STAERHEF EIDO T
TEELEFNA A
T TTOREPLOSTR TOOW IOMNAYEEEO T
TLEELECUOEINOP
ATIS
AMTLL T DRTHIU N
RATULDHI TH TE ISPRUTDEN AOAANNN
F  ALLABE SDAHE BENDPE -FELNDHED
ATTA
ES. S UEHAARDI'MYOETSMS MDPL AV
DEREWAS FT,IL